it's first time I met Chris Brown this
is crazy I'm throwing a party in Miami
when it's me and Colin Farrell Eddie
Murphy was still in it this years back
you like to 2005 me so I'm hosting a
party we're in Miami the crowds going
crazy but in the down like not in the
VIP it's some kids dancing dancing all
this [ __ ]
and so my DJ DJ he goes yo man it's a
new kid Chris Brown he bout to be the
next one I said yeah but he think he can
dance cuz you know I'm not dad
I go [ __ ] him up yeah I'll come down and
[ __ ] him up and it was like okay so I'll
go down now you know it's all about my
time and so everybody's following me I'm
about to go battle whoever this kid is
so I said yeah bro you think you could
dance on I did like some kind of
[ __ ] this is to me we're all jammed
together right he doesn't do a move you
know what he does he's standing in the
middle of the crowd he jumped over the
crowd did the backflip up here and came
straight down and said what's up I said
my [ __ ] I'm gonna leave you the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
Avenger [ __ ]
[Music]